- RISE AND GRIND. NO DAYS OFF.
- OH NO. EVERYONE AT MY SMALL GATHERING, WE OVERSLEPT.
- Ugh, I ate three almonds last night. What happened?
Uh-oh.
- WHOOPS, I BOUGHT A BASEBALL TEAM?
- Hello, city inspector. What’s that?
You’re coming in one hour?!
WE NEED TO CLEAN UP, OR WE CAN’T PLAY. QUICK, SEND A DISTRACTION!
- I’m local miracle Alex Smith! Focus on me!
- What if we delay—
- NO, WE’RE STICKING TO SCHEDULE.
DAN, CHANGE YOUR NAME. THE SPONSORS CARE NOW.
- Uh, we're the...Washington...
Football...
Team.
Dwayne, hurry, make a mascot.
- Jamal, change into something presentable!
- What about player safety? Gridiron Heights has an active volcano!
- Fine, for volcano safety, we’ll ban jersey swaps.
- Aww.
- Get up! Or stay down. I respect you now!
Hey—Hey, why don't we go turn Gronk back on.
- PLEASE SET TIME ON GRONK.
- I’m here to see if the town is to code.
- [Together:] Everything is fine here!
- Interesting.
- Introducing our new mascot:
- [Together:] WE’RE TEAMY THE TEAM MONSTER.
- Ok, so you're good to play football.
- If you thought this video was a homerun, hit the subscribe button.
- What?
- You don’t wanna strike out on future episodes.
- Uh, Kyler, this is a football thing.
- I’ll see you at the World Series.
- Can he not hear me down there?
- Alright thanks for letting me stand on this chair.